what is the number one best
anti-inflammatory food in the entire
world can you take a guess you think
it's omega-3 Fetti acids fish oils not
even close there are so many things that
create inflammation we have gluten we
have refined sugars seed oils alcohol
junk food etc etc but most inflammatory
conditions I'm talking about autoimmune
I'm talking about arthritis type
problems originate in the gut and you
can drink all the fish oil you want it's
not going to do anything you must change
your diet okay and the primary food that
I'm going to recommend that can heal the
gut which is the food that has the most
glutamine glutamine is like a Healer of
your gut and the food that has the most
glutamine is red meat okay beef that is
the food that is the best healer for
your gut